[Music]
which is take it away Thank You Deena
yes so my name is halala dezik I'm
faculty here at UC Berkeley and it's a
great an honor to be able to speak at
this conference original is just gonna
tell you just about one project but
because I've seen how the talks of Gunn
I wanted to give you actually half
15-minute discussion of actually neural
computation the visual cortex is
following up on Ken and a little bit on
what Massimo has talked about but I'm
gonna talk about a different computation
you heard a lot about from Ken which is
contextual modulation and the specific
instance is surrounds the pressure in
the visual cortex so I'm not gonna take
the time to introduce it because Ken
went through that pretty extensively but
I want to show a figure from sort of a
now classic paper from David first
during Ken and where they were making
wholesale recordings from the cat
anesthetized cat and if you give a small
steam as to the CRF the the classical
receptive field you see beautiful
spiking if as can point out if you
increase the size of the stamens you see
a massive suppression of aspiring a
normalization of the firing rates and an
interesting feature is that if you
rotate this around so the the features
of the sender surround are different
like an orientation you notice that you
actually don't get much suppression you
can even get facilitation I'll describe
why we might think this is important in
a second but I just want to point out
that this is a phenomena that's widely
observed across many species and when I
was in Moscow's lab we found it in Mouse
you don't see it under anesthesia so it
probably hadn't been studied prior but
in a wake Mouse it's actually even more
potent I think than you see in cats so
what is a good for this is pure
conceptual one ideas figure-ground
segregation so you're only suppressing
neurons that are sort of encoding
redundant or dependent features like so
helps you identify boundaries or
separate the figure from the ground with
like a grating floating in front of
another grating with a different
orientation Ceylan C and so forth and
the idea is that it's gonna sparse in
the code by suppressing a lot of spikes
that aren't necessary for a coding
redundant information and so making your
code more efficient but I'm gonna focus
really on the mechanisms because that's
and I was coming from aussolas lab we
think we're good at so is this some
cortical a lot of the features of
surround suppression don't suggest this
like it's orientation dependence it's
the fact that it's delayed in time so if
it's cortical is it through increased
inhibition and the initial hypothesis
was yes maybe it's the simplest model
would be that you simply increase some
activity of inhibitory neuron increase
gaba onto the parameters and therefore
divide their firing rates but an
alternative hypothesis also equally
perhaps as simple is that you simply
remove excitation you withdraw
excitation from the cells or not to the
exclusion of either of those it's
actually a change in the ratio of
excitation and emission so which one of
these so I'm not going to go through all
of this paper from ozeki at all which is
the David first during ken miller's
paper and this is the description of the
inhibition stabilized network but the
key idea there was that as you add the
surround over the sensor you get a
transient increase in the eye cell the
inhibitory cell activity that actually
drives the entire network down into a
suppressed state so the net effect is a
withdrawal of excitation and ambition
which is something that you see here
so less excitation less inhibition when
the stimulus is large and then when it
is small so when I was in Massimo's lab
we had been looking at cortical inter
neurons in the awake Mouse we had
observed surround suppression we had
noticed this one class of inter neuron
called the somatostatin inter neuron
that was different than all other types
of cells that we had observed in layer 2
3 that's firing rate increased
monotonically with the size of a
greeting so it itself showed basically
almost no surround suppression so this
is consistent with a model where this
neuron is driven by larger and larger
gratings and would therefore suppress
the pyramidal cells to drive surround
suppression indeed if you optogenetic
lee suppress these cells you can relieve
a lot of surround suppression so this
link the activity of this one particular
relatively rare subtype of inhibitory
cell in surround suppression so how does
this jive with the model of the the isn
and the predictions of the isn and the
data of ozeki at all so I don't think
they're directly it could be compatible
it was assumed they weren't for a while
so I'd like this what we want to do is
to address these
in the context of azuki's experiments
okay so what I did was is I made whole
cell recordings from awake behaving mice
so the experiment we've done previously
was extracellular recordings but we had
to ask what are the interstellar
conductances the excitation inhibition
you see that in red is excitation EPS
Caesar inhibition IPS sees here's just
to represent representative examples of
layer 2 through pyramidal cells that you
can measure in a mouse as you increase
the size of the stimulus now what you
can see in these cells is that
excitation increases a little bit and so
you get to the sort of the the CRF the
receptive fields Bhangra but then you
see definitely prominent suppression or
withdrawal of excitation and inhibition
you see something qualitatively somewhat
different but not that different you
don't see this massive increase in the
mission that monotonically increases
with size it kind of runs up and then it
sort of flattens out or even in many
cells shows suppression so broadly
speaking this is actually pretty
consistent with the work of ozeki a
table that actually as you increase the
size of the stimulus and cells fire less
you see a withdrawal of total synaptic
input but one thing I wanted to point
out that was pretty critical that maybe
wasn't highlighted in the paper of David
first year is that if you compare the
ratio of excitation to inhibition you
see that systematically across many many
cells you see a decrease in the ratio
such that while excitation is absolutely
being withdrawn inhibition is not being
suppressed or withdrawn as much so
there's a net reduction in the ER ratio
and in fact as Ken pointed out before
the break this is a plot from that same
paper from Ken is that indeed you can
see there's a prediction from the
stabiliser super linear network that Ian
odd that that ratio should drop and
indeed that's what we would confirm then
as a side point the same relationship
holds in cats it holds in mice that I
showed here between the spike rate and
the memory potential so the network of
v1 in Mouse looks to act very much like
a stapler lies super lunar network at
least from this perspective so this
really seemed to add further support
that mice and cats are or a mouse is a
little cat is little monkey and in fact
everything you saw in cats you could see
in mice but we now have the ability to
actually ask how do somatostatin cells
do that which you can't right now do the
same cats and monkeys and so you in the
somatostatin cells you express the
optogenetic silence or halorhodopsin
and you simply ask what happens when you
suppress the somatostatin cells on the
excitation and on the inhibition so
black is controlled in with light with
this little bar is an orange and what
you can see here is if you look at the
black this is the size tuning of
excitation you could see its size tune
and the inhibition so slightly less size
tune but certainly not consistent within
just a run up of inhibition but the key
idea here is if you suppress the
somatostatin cells you don't see a
reduction you actually see a massive
increase in excitation and inhibition
and in fact that's a little bit
counterintuitive why would you see an
increase in ambition for suppressing
inhibitory neurons in fact that's a
prediction of inhibition stabilized
network of paradoxical effect and so
what somatostatin cells are clearly
doing is they're suppressing the network
they're driving surround suppression not
by adding net GABAergic inhibition that
you would see at the soma of these cells
but by actually suppressing the network
and driving it withdrawal of both
excitation and emission and so therefore
I think there's a synthesis of this data
between cats and mice that these cells
are critical to drive in to surround
suppression by suppressing the network
in the inhibition stabilized Network
what I wanted to point out one other
interesting thing is a slight tangent
what you're saying is that the
somatostatin population is a small
minority of the other inhibitory
interneurons are intermingled with each
other and what is known about the
connect right okay okay good point
so okay so why is there more inhibition
maybe yeah so there's two reason is two
reasons yes so medicine cells as muscle
on other people are shown directly
inhibit problems yeah and certainly a
lot of this inhibition you're measuring
is from problem cells of the synapse
near the soma but the explanation for
why you see a greater inhibition is
really twofold one is he relieved
surround suppression pyramidal cells
fire more and then drive the PV cells
more so it's the inverse of what's at
Brown suppression is doing in the isn
you could also interpret it and I don't
think that's exclusive as removal
inhibition from the PV cells directly so
it's a combination
I believe the two although the iesson
doesn't require that so I wanted to
point out something slightly different
which is about neural synchronization in
the exact same scenario these exact same
increasing size and I know why would
might this might be interesting is
you're getting suppression you're really
removing a lot of spikes for these large
gratings you're normalizing the firing
rates you're presumably making the code
more efficient and yet there's something
you do want to integrate over contours
you want neurons to be able to sum mate
over contours and recognize boundaries
and so perhaps there's coding not just
in the rate domain but in the temporal
domain such that synchronization between
neurons that are representing say long
contours across their receptive fields
might synchronize in a better way to
drive neurons downstream and this is an
idea proposed decades ago that neurons
will synchronize under certain
conditions where they're basically
processing input that would extend
across their receptive fields when it
has the common features like common
orientation so if you actually look
carefully I only noticed this like a
couple weeks ago and I pointed this to
Ken literally yesterday he didn't notice
it I think if you look at this recording
from ozeki you see that if you look at
so here's there's no surround
suppression no surround suppression
powerful surround suppression if you
look at the sub-threshold vm you see a
massive oscillation of the memory
potential which they didn't I don't
think they made a point of at all in
that paper so that's just highlight you
can see that's an about 25 to 35 Hertz
and so incidentally this is this is
interesting that it notice this in this
paper but if you look in mice and you're
putting extra cell electrode in the
cortex of mice and you increase the
stimulus size to drive surround
suppression you notice that as surround
suppression is going getting stronger so
paramah cells are firing less and less
that the population is getting very
sparse there's a massive increase in
neural synchronization this is very
evident in the local field potential but
it's also evident in the
cross-correlation of neuronal spiking
and so the synchronization plotted here
increases monotonically with size even
as the fire it's decreased monotonically
with size that's also pretty interesting
because if you look at this is the large
greed and giving you a large
synchronization if you do a cross
oriented grading which tries basically
no surround suppression or less this is
on a lot of scale you see a massive
difference a reduction in the
synchronization so when that this is and
I'll show this a little bit later but
basically you get much less
synchronization between regions of the
cortex that are representing cross
oriented features so they don't
synchronize if they're representing
cross oriented features now what
underlies is synchronization so the
hypothesis is inhibition and so if you
actually measure inhibition as I just
showed you and the few slides ago
same-same weeks exactly spare me your
increasing the size of the stimulus but
now we're actually measuring
synchronization in the power spectrum of
this inhibitory current you see that as
stimulus gets larger and larger you see
a massive increase in synchronization
you can see this in these rhythmic
inhibitory currents which come at the
exact same frequency as the local field
potential and the spiking of neurons so
this gave us the hypothesis that since
surround suppression depends on
somatostatin cells and they fire more
and more with increased size they're the
only cell to do that in layer 2 3 to our
knowledge everybody else is suppressed
by larger sizes that they're actually
mediating this effectively if you want
to call a gamma man synchronization and
so you put your hailer at option in your
somatostatin cells and you asked if this
synchronization can be destroyed by
sounding somatostatin cells and indeed
it can and so you had this rhythmic
synchronization close to 30 Hertz that's
really strongly suppressed when you take
out some medicine so so they seem to be
doing two things they're normalizing the
population to drive sparse coding for
surround suppression but at the same
time the spikes that are left behind are
extremely synchronous so maybe they're
basically you can think of they're
removing the non synchronous spikes
that's just want even maybe think of it
that the idea is they're powerfully
synchronized in the cortex particularly
across distant regions of the cortex so
here if you this is Julia beats work in
the lab if you stick to multi electrode
arrays about twenty thirty two degrees
of visual space separated in v1 so
looking down on v1 you have these two
electrodes you can measure the
synchronization of neurons and l.f.t.s
between these two electrodes and you see
for a large cross oriented grading that
covers the receptive fields of these two
electrodes massive synchronization
between those two electrodes and this is
measured in this coherence plot so very
very high coherence but if you suppress
somatostatin cells that coherence
becomes substantially reduced so
somatostatin cells are meeting this
long-range synchronization one sees
specifically
for these ISO oriented gradings but not
for the cross or integrated so just to
conclude this first part the idea is
that surround suppression is sort of
canonical computation that we see in the
visual system and in many other systems
is mediated by withdrawal and excitation
and inhibition and a reduced by ratio
and that's maybe the key thing I think
this was probably in ozaki's data but
wasn't pointed out also shown by Jeff
Isaacs inin in the auditory system very
recently yeah synchronized so they tend
to have the same orientation as each
other or because it's weird if you have
how does how does who knows whether it's
across we're integrating or not I mean
those guys of all orientations so do
these large field gratings specifically
synchronize only the opposite of the
orthogonal a oriented cells or these
well under this condition is there's low
firing rates the spikes you gather from
cells that prefer this orientation so in
this in a mouse layer 2 3 the really the
only thing you can observe firing among
the pyramidal cells are cells that
prefer these horizontal greetings so
yeah the answer would be that if their I
so oriented then they synchronize I'm
not saying they couldn't synchronize
cross oriented and maybe there is
synchronization of cells that prefer
different orientations but yeah
definitely this is dominated by neurons
in layer 2 3 that are prefer their
responses for this orientation is there
an explanation for that increased
coherence I like low frequencies
yeah I am NOT under cent that is really
reproducible this is one example talking
about frequencies so this is twenty
thirty Hertz yeah yeah I'm not so sure
this is an interesting point you know
you get three reviewers they each have a
different you look at twenty gamma
papers they all assigned different look
that's a little bit semantics I can get
into that I want to talk about the other
stuff but basically yeah you could call
it a gamma if you look in monkeys if we
consider that the important they had
this exact thing it's at forty Hertz but
has all the exact same features its size
tune everything is the same mice are a
little bit slower that's all I can say
might be the biophysics of the neurons
or the synapses so I would you know you
can call this gamma that's what I would
call it but if I to me doesn't matter
what somatostatin cells are doing is
they're synchronizing populations and
neurons across the retinotopic field
okay so yes so surround suppression is
mediated by actually withdrawal of
excitation and emission that the somme
cells that the way they drive
suppression is by withdrawing and i were
by suppressing the entire network and
they synchronize their remaining spikes
which perhaps is a good mechanism for
temporal coding of say extended contours
of course that's clearly a contentious
hypothesis maybe with manipulations that
some cells in the future
target emit relations you might be able
to ask whether this synchronization is
even good for say sensory perception
okay so i'm gonna shift gears for a
little moment and talk about what we
realized that when I started the lab
here a few years ago and Berkeley is
that the one photon optogenetics we were
doing was useful it was genetically
targeted but it didn't have the
precision in space and time that we
really wanted to understand how ensemble
activity in the cortex drive sensory
perceptions and so you know optogenetics
is very powerful and this is a drawing
or artist rendition of optogenetics from
ed Boyden website but of course this is
completely fanciful you can't shine a
blue flash light on one neuron in the
brain this is what optogenetics often
looks like in many labs around the world
and so what opera geneticists are using
is the advantage of the genetic
targeting not so much the spatial
targeting and we needed spatial
targeting in the cortex in particular
because you have you know thousands of
pyramidal cells that are not so
differentiable genetically and we wanted
to write patterns of activity in the
brain that serve as
lucien millisecond precision so what do
we need so exactly that so if we're
gonna create patterns in the brain that
would mimic physiological patterns and
therefore allow us to causally relate
these patterns to perception and ask key
questions merit neural coding we need to
be able to manipulate cells one at a
time or ensembles but with cellular
resolution major question in the cortex
is how much information is encoded in
the timing of spikes we don't know the
answer completely so we wanted to be
able to have a tool that could get us to
this so it had to have millisecond
precision didn't exist had to operate in
three dimensions which is non-trivial in
some optical systems and a need to
control a large number of neurons and do
it at very high speed so basically you
want to operate at the speed and scale
of sensory percepts in the primary
sensory cortex so we turn to a
technology called two photon holography
or computer-generated holography
pioneered by a number of groups
including that of Valentina Mulyani
and basically the idea here is you take
your infrared two photon laser beam so
it propagates their brain tissue very
effectively and this is the key part of
the system which is a spatial light
modulator it's device that takes this
Gaussian wave front of light and
basically reshapes it through phase
modulation into a three dimensional
pattern of light and I'll show you that
in the next slide and so we came up with
a tool that basically overcome a bunch
of technical limitations that I won't
bore you with we call this 3d shot or
three-dimensional scan lists holographic
optogenetics with temporal focusing but
the key idea here is that you can
generate with a single shot of a laser a
single femtosecond pulse can be reshaped
into this three-dimensional pattern of
light each of these blobs of light has
been designed to be about the size of
one pyramidal cell in layer 2/3 of the
mouse cortex and you can place as many
up to hundreds of spots in a small
volume and anywhere you want basically
in the 3d and so this allows you at
least optically to pass light onto the
neurons of interest that are defined by
you or defined by the data you've
collected in this animal so this this
solves the optical problem it gives you
sell your resolution I won't show you
the data that verifies that it's
published and it operates inherently in
3d because it's a holographic approach
but I was actually challenging for
temporal focusing for the aficionados in
the room but it does this but now the
question is really one a millisecond
precision which turned out to be a
bigger challenge and we wanted to
control large numbers of neurons at high
speed which also is a technical
challenge so for us to achieve
millisecond precision if you're
interested in recreating patterns of
activity in the brain with extremely
high fidelity it turns out that you're
limited by the option protein to
microbial opsin I'm sure many of you
familiar with Chan or Dobson chatter
adopts and for a number of reasons is
not good so what we needed was an option
that was extremely fast on and off to
give us this precision in time it had to
be very very strong you can only cook so
much light in the brain before if the
brain heats up or the cell basically
turns into a plasma and you have to have
the right special sensitivity in
particular because you want to be
imaging gcamp at the same time which has
certain spectral sensitivity you don't
have crosstalk okay so long story short
we tried like 20 options that none of
them are good enough and so we realized
we had to actually engineer an option
specifically designed for multiphoton
holographic optogenetics and so we lined
up the sequences this is the amino acid
sequences of many different cation
options that had existed some natural
some synthetic and we actually looked at
the best option out there in terms of
speed which was called Cronus really
amazingly fast designed by nature also
pretty potent but there was something
pretty amazing about Kronos is that
every other option except for Kronos at
this one particular residue which lines
the the conductive pore of this channel
for every other option like chana Dopson
was a glutamate a charge residue for
this was a Metheny which made us think
that's pretty interesting my finding for
those who don't know is quite different
from glutamate it's not charged it's
much bulkier and so we reasoned that if
we manipulated this residue turned it
back to a glutamate it might be a lot
better so we call this option Chronos
from affine into glutamate or Chrome and
indeed if you look at the photo currents
you can get so this is voltage clamp
photo currents from a bunch of regular
options people have used and this is
from the option this is literally a
point mutation in Chronos you get
basically a four-fold increase and that
fourfold increase was really necessary
because if you look at the current you
need to spike a cell in the cortex in
particular layer-2 a few parameter cells
are just not very excitable
they're hyperpolarized they've low in
per resistance these options don't get
you to this threshold level this dashed
line that reliably spikes a cell but
chrome does that no problem and so if
you look at the fraction of cells you
can spike under any kid
which is just more light you can spike
basically 100 almost 100% of chrome
cells so that's we had to do that so we
use that moving forward and we asked
given this option which is still very
fast but also very potent can we replay
a pattern of activity that would look
basically like a normal pattern of
activity in the quartz accents for that
we generated a pattern of activity that
was basically Poisson and statistics
such that they're coming randomly in
time this is a raster plot of the
holographic pulses we deliver to the
neuron then we put a loose patch
electrode under the two-photon guidance
on a cell express in the option and we
measure the spikes given each pulse of
light we overlay that quantify that
statistically and the bottom line is for
this example that about 96% of the time
that you want one spike you get exactly
one spike not zero and not two and
importantly the jitter of that spike is
less than a millisecond it could be as
little as a hundred microseconds because
you're getting these very large fast
photo currents so you can replay a
pattern of activity basically much more
fidelity than the cortex would ever give
you right because these neurons are
firing somewhat stochastic lis okay so
the very slight tangent you also want to
delete specific spikes for other
purposes of very briefly we use an anion
Chen R Dobson so an opsin that actually
fluxes chloride we had to engineer in a
number of ways so it wasn't toxic and
indeed same exact microscope could
suppress the spikes of the cell both
rapidly within a few milliseconds and
very potent Li but I'm not going to talk
much about that okay so last thing I
want to discuss is how do you actually
use this microscope for doing biology
experiments so we wanted a system that
can both read and write simultaneously
do it in three dimensions high speed
large scale and so the way you do this
is you build a microscope with both a
two photon laser scanning microscope for
gcamp imaging and a second arm that does
the holographic multiphoton optogenetics
and so here here's one cell oh man you
can't see that but basically you can
make sure you're firing each cell by
simply measuring its calcium response to
your pulses and this is increasing the
laser energy targeted to like one
particular cell you get a dose response
curve and you pick the amount of light
okay you want to target that cell just
to make sure you don't want too much
light you want too little light you want
it to get spiking you know 90 100
percent of the time
okay so this is a movie in which you're
imaging two planes a little bit like
that mark Sheffield was probably showing
you yeah you're just tuning your
microscope lens the the optogenetics is
done inherently 3d the imaging is done
sort of semi sequentially but almost
simultaneously in 3d and so here's just
two example planes at 250 and 200
microns below the peel surface a green
arrow comes up when you're gonna
stimulate that cell with a hologram and
we're doing one cell at a time this is
playing in a loop and you can see that
the cell fires that's red and so you can
play one cell at a time and you can do
it selectively in 3d you can quantify
this with a calcium raster plot where
red indicates fire and these are
different trials so the cell fire is
very reliably and you do this for a
sequence of such cells and you can
generate a very precise temporal
sequence to take it to extreme alan
Mardon lee who did all these experiments
beside okay let me try 134 neurons in a
three-dimensional volume and here's the
data from that here's five individual
trials so I have five repetitions and
you can see pretty reliable you can
generate this temporal sequence of
activity where firing one cell after the
other but this really wasn't what we
wanted to do what we wanted to do was to
play ensembles of activity since all
codes are population-based
and so here you can target multiple
cells at a time same exact configuration
as before but you're hitting a groups of
cells at a time you can see that they're
flashing and so this shows you about
five or ten cells we want to expand this
so it currently you're actually limited
in how you measure spikes then how you
deliver them calcium imaging has some
constraints but regardless here's a
movie of three planes where we're
stimulating different numbers of cells
the arrows flash real briefly and then
we're doing up to 50 cells spread across
this hundred 150 micron volume so while
we can't measure millisecond precision
with calcium I can tell you we're fairly
confident these spikes are coming in
with millisecond precision and so forth
and with basically quasi cellular
resolution so all the activity are
actually seeing this is a quiescent
Mouse you're seeing is actually driven
by our holographic stimulation this is
just arbitrary pattern stimulation but
the question is so how would you use
this microscope and so my lab is
interested in neural coding for sensory
perception I think
most of us are and so the idea is we
actually train license lab to
discriminate different objects with
their whiskers we've mostly studied the
barrel cortex mice are quite easy to
train to discriminate objects I'll just
you know give you an example like
differentiating a sphere and a cube so
they can do this with their whiskers and
you can measure with calcium the
patterns of activity that naturally
occur when an animal is touching
different objects yeah and so once you
can measure those patterns and this is
what neuro scientists have done for
decades they correlated activity with
stimuli we then want to flip it on its
head and ask if those patterns can
causally drive the perception we can
quantify this because the animals
basically doing the equivalent of two
different levers pressing lever a for
stimulus a and letter B for stimulus B
so if we can fool the animal by putting
in a specific spatial temporal pattern
because it'll pres lever B even when the
object is not actually presented to the
object so there been a number of groups
that have generated sort of perceptions
though not specific they'll shine
thousands of neurons with blue light so
one photon optogenetics or even micro
stimulate one or a small number of
neurons to generate a de novo person
it's not a specific person it's not for
us but it's probably just some sort of
buzz in their brain we want to generate
a specific percept and so we take those
patterns and we would play them back
into the brain this is what we're
literally doing right now and ultimately
let's say that works and there's reasons
why it may or may not work let's say it
does then the key question is if I play
a pattern that's physiological and I get
the animal to perceive a cube and then I
begin to parametric we order alter that
pattern so which cells fire how much
each cells fire the sequence that
different cells fire or the temporal
synchronization of the activity since we
have basically arbitrary control of
those parameters we can ask one by one
which parameter is most effective at
driving this percept in particular say
over that perceptor what is the logic
and syntax of the code that drive these
distant different sensory perceptions
and so that is certainly where we are
right now and these are the funding
sources and I thank you for listening
so hey tremendously cool really need me
about this working the other thing I can
imagine you can do with this so it's
always challenging for those of us who
do a lot of electrophysiology to sort of
know exactly what calcium signals mean
and the power liable they are and
obviously two-photon is much more
reliable than one photon we don't have a
data set now and a technique that
potentially means that you can really at
least for this system evaluate that
rigorously so what do you know what are
you seeing in this particular system for
calcium signals in terms of your
estimate the calibration of the gcamp
yeah for example like how often does the
single spike not video I would say
rarely in our wake behaving - is a
single spike easily detectable but maybe
other people are way better but you know
clearly two or three spikes are quite
detectable but you're saying have we
done a systematic characterization I
would still probably put an electrode on
one of these cells and do that exact
experiment we're also putting multi
electrode arrays in and doing that
experiment to ask is your mountain sort
very good find out but that's that's
good because you can I mean first of all
you can't necessarily only every time
you stimulate you're gonna spike one
cell you're gonna bias strongly itself
maybe another cell will spike
occasionally if it happens to be highly
depolarize and get a little bit of light
so there's some issues but yeah it tells
me like you're as interested in defining
GABA functionally as in terms of just
frequency what the Freeman's believe
that Gavin was actually result of
feedback
yes okay I think that's it literally
when I up so somatostatin cells are feed
back into neurons okay so absolutely
that hypothesis I believe is true let's
say that we could establish that neurons
could do a Fourier transform with that
satisfy you I in what context perception
sure I guess that satisfied yes I think
I think
I'm wondering just tell the difference
between I'm pretty confident you could
do that
so BMI a little bit works like that it's
been done with calcium and dense hope
those are coming but yeah we haven't
tried it it's an interesting question
that you can ask can they tell they're
missing two very similar spike trains
with one spike jittered I mean you could
play all these games is that informative
with maybe a philosophical discussion
we're trying to ask what features of the
natural stimulus would best correlate
with perception that that is in the
mouse doing a task but yeah you can
definitely do that and I think it would
work because you're gonna drive down
activity downstream right the activity
we're generating of these twenty or
fifty or a few hundred cells in layer
two three has to propagate which I'm
sure it does down to layer five and
other cortical areas okay alternative
hypothesis yep you showed very nice that
when you get a sequential activation you
basically get one to one do you see the
same fidelity when you
when you say fidelity you mean spatial
resolution or what do you mean no oh
wait so we did do that yep I said well
you're worried about like network stuff
yeah okay so under anesthesia when we
did what there's not a lot it works fine
so what we did is we patch one cell and
we steam it like 30 cells and we just
see how that one cell responded and then
it does respond very precisely but of
course as you recruit many cells
particularly an active network are
getting inhibition if you look at this
movie by the way no no I'm not worried
either what's cool I mean this was but
certainly a good reviewer question for
us is is that there are definitely cells
that respond that are not being driven
they're actually 50 100 microns away
from any hologram but you know cortex
highly we're currently connected these
are all excitatory cells we know that
here because genetically but if I better
if you're measuring somatostatin cells
they'd be firing like med which you know
muscles like we would stimulate these
cells with one photon and the first
thing to trigger was a somatostatin cell
probably here we can actually ask how
many cell are needed to drive I mean ma
Smosh they do patch-clamp but you can
ask you can actually parameterize the
whole thing like how many cells are
needed to drive a certain type of cell
or something like that how many spikes
in a certain time window
yeah I mean this is probably going to
get not very informative question I'm
just curious what you think right so I
really like the approach the issue is
that there are very few trials right so
let's imagine you could get 500 trials
out of a mouse a day you probably only
want to stimulate on say 20% of that
that leaves you with a hundred for house
yeah you want to detect the behavioural
effect in the mouse that's doing like 70
percent right I took so I I'm curious if
in this way of parametrically changing
patterns effective in Ian I'm just
curious to hear it yeah where to study
enough trials have so few trials that
you literally sort of going after the
space I mean may be possible in many
days I'm just curious to to hear what
you're interpreting correct I mean you
can't get enough statistical power on
many different combinations in one Mouse
in one day you have to average over many
mice and many bees look you can do this
for months in the same animal so at
least if you can collate across days on
one animal you can get thousands and
thousands of trials on a single Mouse
and then you have enough postdocs they
can do thousands of mice okay but you're
right there's a strip there's a problem
that you can't get all this data in a
single session in a single Mouse and
you're right only 20% or 30% of the
trials will be take out the physical
statements and put in the optogenetics
to miss otherwise a lot of things bad
happen if you keep just emailing the
brain
yep and the slide for you but the key
thing here you're talking my the optical
crosstalk is that this ops in chrome has
some absorbance at the nine 20th line
and because it so it can't get severe if
your option is very slow but because our
option is super fast as the laser flies
across the dwell time is very low and
you get a blip of about a millivolt
provided your image and alert volume if
they're zoom out into one cell it's like
a spiral scan you'll fire this up so far
the actual modification by the truck the
crosswalk is pretty low I wish it was
better but it's probably negligible
compared to the background activity in
these cells which is mass Dwarfs that no
not really
again if you zoom in you knew maybe you
[ __ ]
[Applause]